notre fille océane s'est suicidée le 4
juin dernier suite à un viol qu'elle a
subi le 10 février par une personne
qu'elle pensait être son meilleur ami
dans son appartement d'étudiante à
beaune avant ce viol elle avait déjà
subi un viol à une soirée de nouvel an
il ya trois ans et une agression
sexuelle par son patron en janvier
dernier un mois avant le viol alors ça
c'est des veaux plainte qu'elle a fait
deux ans et demi après son premier viol
qui était au nouvel an 2010 est
ensuite elle avait 17 ans elle avait 17
ans elle a mis deux ans et demi pour le
courage et les porter plainte ça c'est
la plainte contre son patron d'une
agression ça a été violent et elle a
déposé plainte dans la foulée l'effet
janvier 2022 la plagne janvier 2022 et
ça c'est la pire des trois affaires par
son ami il ya six pages de moi parce que
moi j'ai jamais le courage de vivre
parce que je pense que je deviendrais
fou si joli si je disais à tous les
détails il vous faudra vous l'avez lu
oui j'ai eu du travail tout de suite
la première on vient d'apprendre qu'elle
a été classée sans suite on vient de
l'apprendre parce que personne ne nous a
tenu au courant la deuxième elle doit
être en cours mais on ne sait rien du
tout la dernière est en cours la
troisième affaire est en cours nous quoi
et encore rien non plus donc en fait
dans l'impression qu'à chaque fois ça
avance pas la première star où elle a
porté plainte sahamies pareil on a deux
ans chaque jour qui passait c'était
comme s'il y avait un an qui passait
c'était trop trop long pour elle c'est
pensé que ça allait être plus rapide que
ça puisqu'elle allait peut-être plus
prise au sérieux plus prises en charge
et vous c'est quoi votre sentiment vous
avez le sentiment aussi que la justice
est très lente oui j'y vis des violences
faites en fait ça donne pas envie aux
victimes d'aller porter plainte parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on n'est pas
prise au sérieux et que en plus ça
traîne ça traîne on sait on nous dit
même pas pourquoi ça traîne c'est tout
élan tout est long j'ai l'impression
qu'on est en dessous de la pile je ne
sais combien d'affaires ccc quand on est
victime je pense qu'on veut que ce soit
vite action réaction c'est on veut vite
que notre bourreau il paye quoi elle
avait perdu confrontation avec son avec
son son violeur et elle avait peur que
la justice ne l'écoutent pas ne la crois
pas depuis donc le 10 février on l'a
récupéré chez nous à la petite cuillère
et trois mois prêt début mai elle nous
dit papa maman vous allez être contents
j'ai enfin le courage avait porté
plainte elle a été porté plainte le
policier qui était quelqu'un de très
sympa mais il a été très pessimiste avec
elle il lui a dit ah le problème c'est
que le viol il a dit à 3 - l'arrière que
le type de drogue que vous avez dû
ingurgiter bas ne reste pas longtemps
dans le corps c'était quoi comme drogue
on pense que c'est du ghb ou similaires
puisque la nuit elle avait les bras et
les jambes complètement paralysé le
policier lui a dit que l'analyse allait
mettre entre quatre et six mois
qu'il y avait une chance sur un million
qui retrouve des traces de drogue parce
qu'il s'était passé trois mois entre le
viol et la prise d'échantillons et en
plus ce sac l'entre-temps l'afm couleurs
donc ayant fait une couleur et encore
moins une chance qu'on retrouve des
traces de cette drogue donc il lui a dit
le problème c'est que si on ne retrouve
aucune trace de drogue dans vos cheveux
s'il avoue pas ça va être compliqué ça
va être parole contre parole ça ça lui a
miné le moral elle est rentrée chez nous
mais elle a dit mais personne peut faire
quelque chose pour moi bon vous vous
m'écoutez mais vous pouvez pas m'aider
les psychologues ils peuvent écouter
même pas m'aider je vais enfin avoir les
policiers qui m'écoutent ils peuvent pas
m'aider non plus nous on n'a pas trouvé
de mots et son suicide mais c'est le
gendarme qui nous a dit que le médecin
légiste trouve un mot sur l on sait pas
où ils étaient cachés sur l demain elle
a laissé juste mes phrases à la
profession on aurait adoré qu'elle nous
met papa moment je vous aime on aurait
un message personnel une lettre mais
elle a juste écrit un petit mot sur un
repas pierre peut-être que dans la
précipitation qu'elle appelle temps de
faire plus et elle mais juste un petit
papier je suis déjà mortes depuis le 10
février vous n'aurez rien pu faire pour
moi je pensais pas comme ça il ya une
semaine en arrière plan c'est un pavé
dans la mare en remettant juste un petit
peu ce sur facebook je pensais pas que
ça allait être les sur twitter sur un
stade qui sont des réseaux sociaux
j'utilise pas j'ai reçu une quarantaine
cinquantaine de messages donc à 99 % des
femmes qui me disent qu'elles ont vécu
la même histoire qu'océane or certaines
qui m'ont dit qu'elles n'ont jamais le
courage allait porter plainte d'autres
qui m'ont dit qu'elles ont été porté
plainte mais qu
elles ont jamais été écoutés que ou
alors si l on est écouté que le dossier
n'avance pas ça fait deux ans que ça
fait trois ans oui comme comme s'il y
avait un problème alors je peux
comprendre peut-être aussi que la
justice et la police y ont débordé
d'affaires peut-être qu'il manque de
moyens comme les hôpitaux et comme les
écoles mais je pense que il faut prendre
prend tout de suite la mesure
en
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui vous avez décidé de
médiatiser cette affaire oui pour que
pour que l'on puisse être entendue que
c'est un n'ai pas subi tout ça pour rien
que cette histoire serve à beaucoup de
femmes où beaucoup de ceux qui subissent
la même chose et
qu est que notre affaire puisse avancer
mais que celle des autres aussi ça
puisse les aider dans leurs démarches
dans leur motivation allait porter
plainte
que tout ça n'est pas servi à rien et
que océane bel emblème elle aurait voulu
ça